look I won't have a bit of a serious
conversation with you here today maybe
it's gonna be a different angle we'll go
but I think for the right person it can
make a massive impact in the way you
view a life because today's a very
interesting time where everybody
majority dude people are telling you to
only think about yourself not your
parents not your kids that your peers
that's your running mate not not anybody
just think about yourself and then in
the middle of the video I'm gonna show
you something that's sitting on my lap
right now that's worth around six seven
hundred thousand dollars maybe you don't
have a message for you but let me get
right into it look there are three
communities that are relying on you and
I on the way we live our lives what you
do in your 70 80 90 100 years of living
impacts these three different
communities let me go through each one
of them one of them are people who are
no longer here with us they are dead the
second one other people that are here
with you today they're living and the
third one is people that are not here
today
because their unborn they may be born
next year ten years from 100 years from
now but they're not here today let me go
through each one of them
why are dead people relying on you today
let me explain to you my last name is
Beth David Wright my mother's last name
is [ __ ] my mother said came from
Armenia Yerevan and when the whole
Stalin Lenin thing happened they were
the whole and then the Armenian genocide
took place and the Assyrian genocide
took place with the Ottoman Empire the
Turkish Empire one and a half million
Armenians were obviously gone through
the genocide so my family escaped with a
latke they came down from Caspian Sea
latke means a boat and they came to a
city called danderp a lobby which is a
northern part of Iran and they stayed
there my dad's family escaped Iraq which
used to be Syria and they went and lived
in Tehran and then my mom and my dad met
and I'm boom I'm born I've never met my
grandfather for my dad said I've never
met my great great grandparents I don't
know their story I can't sit with them
for them to tell me the amount of
sacrifices they've made I don't know
what it was like trying to make sure
your wife survived or your daughter
doesn't get caught up by one of these
Souls I don't know what that's like
I don't know that pain I don't know the
fear I don't know what it's like to wake
up in the morning knowing you've seen so
many of your families being dead I don't
know that and we're very quick to forget
the amount of sacrifices the people that
are not here with us today made for the
unborn which is you and I
we were not born I wasn't born yet why
would they doing that for me because
they were thinking about my father and
through my father they were thinking
about me that means a lot to me should
mean a lot to you the second one is the
people that are living today a lot of
people that are living today are reliant
on the way you and I live the leg is
your example this could be our parent
this could be our brothers sister this
doesn't mean we need to give everybody
money and solve everybody's problems but
the way we live maybe it's our kids
maybe it's you know our people that we
work with in the business these are
people that are counting on the way we
live because they're gonna tell the
story you're your legacy and last but
not least is the unborn this could be
your future kid you may not have a kid
right now
this could be your future granddaughter
this could be your future
daughter-in-law this could be somebody
that's gonna be your great-great-great
son who maybe one day is gonna be a
president or prime minister of some
country you don't know that but it's the
unborn see the dead the living the
unborn
all three automatic to you and I why am
I saying this to you are we going on
such a deep message today you see this
card right here they call it the holy
grail of hockey cards this is a Wayne
Gretzky hockey card 1979 opechee PSA 10
there's only two DS in the world this
sold in nineteen in 2016 is so for four
hundred sixty-four thousand dollars the
same exact one some tell me this is
worth seven hundred thousand dollars
today sometime these worth six hundred
thousand dollars today but I have a
buyers today that wants to pay 750 for
this because he also owns the other one
why is it so valuable let's talk about
it so Wayne Gretzky first of all the
value of this thing relies on a few
different things number one there's only
two of these cars in the world number
two the surface the the corners the
edges the centering all of that matters
number three is what this guy did when
nobody was watching the Gretzky last
name will forever be remembered for what
this guy did during that thirty years of
practice as a kid with this family and
then by himself he was disciplined and
the kind of a teammate he was the kind
of a running mate he was the kind of an
individual he was on a team where he
gave more assists than anybody else he
gave more goals for team than anybody
else he made such an impact in can
and in LA when he was here to the point
where somebody like me is willing to
spend the kind of money to buy this card
why let me explain why I'm going with
this part again see it's very easy to
live life and go through the typical
four stages that we go through stage
number one is survival you try to make
money so you can survive pay the bills
expenses and I know what it is to do
that I know what it is to be in that
forty nine thousand dollars and you're
Bank of America checking accounts as -
743 that's why I kept all my statements
till today I kept every statement on my
credit cards till today I kept my
time-warner critter
that I own because the cable machine I
didn't give back I owed them $750
because of late fees I kept everything
today because it reminds me of this guy
yes I'm sitting in a foreigner some
thousand dollar car yes I've had all the
different things yes I'm you know
fifteen thousand square foot home three
stories elevators on yes all of that
stuff and I love that stuff I mean I
don't have any problem with that stuff
that I have that I'm not I'm not
pitching that in a way of that must be
the Almighty but nothing is close to the
legacy that's left for the people that
are not here with me today if I believe
in the higher law god that one day I'm
gonna reunite with my great-grandfather
that I never had a chance to speak to my
great great grandfather that I never had
a chance to break bread with and tell me
what kind of sacrifices you made for me
to be Who I am today I get a lot of the
credit today for bid David but I'm
nobody what I would shoe did I may not
even exist if you didn't take care of my
dad because I'd never be born
what you do with my mom for my mom you
know that was your granddaughter I mean
I have so much I want to have that
conversation one day I want to have the
conversation with the people that I'm
running with today to say I mean you can
count on Pat so one thing about Pat if
you're in business with Pat that dude is
somebody that I'd go to war with that
matters to me to be a good teammate to
be a good leader to be somebody that you
know somebody so many of you guys pull
me aside and you tell me things like Pat
you don't even know the positive impacts
being made in the world that matters and
it automatic
it's not for notoriety it's to say that
the world came way before
me and I'm just a small little thing
speck I'm gonna come and I'm they're
gone but I want to make sure that time
that I have a making impact same as you
and then the unborn
my kids are seven six and three they
don't have any kids right now and
they're probably not gonna have kids for
a while I think about my granddaughter
and my grandson that God will have one
day I think about who my sons gonna
marry my sons are gonna marry my
daughter's gonna marry I think about
those things I think about society
America that this has been handed to me
today generationally I want to hopefully
make the country better and the world
better with the influence I can so my
son my daughter my kids can one day go
enjoy it as well I owe it to the next
generation because this generation was
given to me due to the prior generation
and it's getting better it's a great
time to be living today so I told you
this was a bit of a serious message
today see one day people gonna walk over
our tombstone our grave whatever you
want to call it they'll go to a funeral
and the family members that love us
again look oh my gosh we love this
person then the people that we ran with
will come and they'll say wow this guy
was a great guy to be working with sky
made an impact then they'll be strangers
that will show up that I've never met
you before but they'll say man sky made
an impact in my life and I've never even
met him and they'll cry because the
impact you make there are many people
like that
this man impacted my life I've done that
when many people you know when I go to
the cemetery nicey them and I sit there
next that I never met you before I'll
say I've never met you before my man
thank you for your courage let me tell
you something thank you
you inspire me you inspire me even
though you're not here this is why the
painting on my wall consists of
everybody that's dead except for one
person and that's me dead people inspire
me because they made an impact for our
lives to be better I told you this is a
deeper talk deeper message but I hope
you internalize it because one day
someone's gonna look back and they're
gonna ask you you may not even be Iran
they're gonna be grateful for the life
you lived or you'll be somebody that'll
be remembered for one generation to
generations and forgotten after that for
the right person listening to this and
watching this if that gave you the
chills and it makes you think about
the dead the living and the unborn I
certainly hope this inspires you to live
life in a different way moving forward
not just the rest of the earth the file
on your the next five years ten years 20
years 50 years however all you are for
the rest your life I hope this makes you
look at life in a complete different way
and I hope you have the courage to do
something about it because that's the
toughest part having said that if it's
yes comment below if you're fully
committed to it and if you haven't yet
made that decision yet maybe today is a
good day for you to think about a little
bit
having said that have a killer week have
a great rest of the month love you take
care bye bye